The sixth most common question asked by
the non-Muslim regarding Islam is if a
man can marry more than one woman then
why can't women in Islam marry more than
one man? If polygeni is allowed in Islam
why is polyandri not allowed?
And the reply to this question can be
given in brief that Allah has given
the woman who you can marry in surah
nisa chapter 4 verse number 20 to 24 the
woman who you can marry and who you
cannot marry is given. Surah nisa ch 4
verse number 24 says you cannot marry
the woman who's already married. So
Quran is clearcut in surah Nisa ch 4
verse number 24 that a woman cannot have
more than one husband simultaneously. So
you cannot marry a woman who's already
married. Now what are the reasons?
Number one that if a man has more than
one wife and if the child is born you
can easily identify who is the father
and who is the mother. Very easy. But if
a woman has more than one husband, you
can identify who is the mother but
you'll not come to know who is the
father. So if you go to school to to
give admission, you may have to give two
father's name or three father's name.
Now we come to know that today science
tells us that if you cannot identify the
parent especially the father, the child
has a very traumatic childhood. If you
know who the mother is, if you don't
know who the father is and especially
the children of prostitutes, you know
they have a the children have a
traumatic childhood very dangerous. So
Islam does not believe in this.
Identifying the parents, mother and
father is very important. So therefore
in Islam if you do polygen you can
identify both the parents but if you do
polyandry you can only identify the
mother not the father. I'm aware today
recently a few years before or a decade
earlier there is genetic testing with
the help of genetic testing you can come
to know who is the mother and who is the
father but this came recently Islam is
there since time memorial since 1400
years old the Quran is revealed it's not
new and of course there are some issues
in but even if I agree it's correct you
can't carry a certificate always oh this
is genetic testing certificate I belong
to this man not to the other
Yet you'll have people slandering you or
laying objections. But this is not the
only reason that you cannot identify the
mother and father. There's a various
reason. Number two, man is more
polygamous in nature than the woman.
That means a man requires more sexual
partners as compared to a woman. This is
scientifically, biologically and
medically. Number three, biologically
and physically the makeup of man differs
than that of a woman. For a man, it is
possible for him to do the role of
multiple husbands. If he's involved in
polygeni, if a man has more than one
wife, he can very well do the role of
multiple husband easily. But if a woman
has more than one husband because of a
ministr cycle because of the estrogen
level being released it's extremely
difficult for her to do the role of
multiple wise and that's the reason in
Islam a man has been told that when the
woman undergoes menstrual cycle you have
to be kind and soft to her. Islam does
not allow a man to give divorce when the
woman is undergoing a menstrual cycle
because during menstrual cycle her
emotional level changes and at that time
you should not give divorce wait till
the menstrual cycle is over. So Islam
takes care of the woman during a
menstrual cycle. So in this period
imagine to take care of one husband is
okay but if she under goes these
physical biological and psychological
changes and if she has more than one
husband for her to do the role of
multiple husband is extremely difficult.
Point number four, today's science tells
us that if a woman has multiple sexual
partners or she's involved in poly and
marriages, she has multiple husbands and
all of them are truthful, there is no
extraarital sex. But if one woman has
three four husband, there is chances of
ventral or sexual diseases emerging in
the woman which can be transmitted back
to the husbands
which is not the case. If a man has
multiple wives and all of them are
lawful to each other just because each
woman has only one sexual partner, there
is no chances of vendor and sexual
diseases emerging. So that's the reason
in Islam polygeni is allowed where a man
can have more wives where even if he has
multiple wives there'll be one there'll
be no ventral disease there'll be no
sexual disease but if a woman has
multiple husbands which Islam does not
allow and if she has more than one
sexual partners there'll be vendal and
sexual diseases which can emerge and be
transmitted back to the husband. So
these are few reasons that we can think
logically why Islam and Allah subhanana
wa ta'ala has not permitted polyandry.
Allah knows there'll be multiple more
reasons why polyandry is not allowed and
polyen is permitted.